hello everybody and welcome to my second
video on how neural nets learn if you
haven't seen the first video on feature
visualization I would really recommend
that you check that one out first and
then come back to this video so let's
start with a riddle what do you see in
this image I think we can all agree that
we see a temple right here and if we
feed this image through a deep
convolutional network it agrees that it
sees a temple here with a very high
certainty okay so how about this image
well you would say it's exactly the same
image right as do I but if you feed this
image through the neural network it says
with 99% certainty that this right here
is an ostrich instead of a temple what
the hell is going on and so this second
image didn't come from a real-world
camera but instead it was hand
engineered specifically to fool the
neural network classifier while being
exactly the same to our visual system
and this is what we call an adversarial
example and to give you guys an idea of
why this is a very significant threat to
a lot of real-world machine learning
applications considering the following
examples so I think we all want our
future self driving cars to be very good
at classifying stop signs right but what
if you can hand engineer a stop sign
that to a self-driving car looks like an
infinite speed limit this is a problem
and did you know that it is possible to
create a pair of 3d printed glasses that
when you put them on all of a sudden you
are unrecognizable to any existing
facial recognition software in the world
or what about printing a custom license
plate that looks perfectly normal but
that gets missed registered by any
existing traffic speed camera if you're
starting to get a feel of the really
important issues that surround these
topics then I hope you're ready to dive
in deep because this episode is on the
crazy world of adversarial examples my
name is Xander and welcome to archive
insights
so in the previous video we saw that we
can use gradient descent on the input
pixels of an image to generate images
that maximally excite it shows a neuron
in a deep neural network and we can use
this technique to visualize features
that the network is learning in the
images now instead of just generating
images that are very good at exciting a
hidden neuron inside a network it turns
out that you can apply the same
procedure and excite a neuron in the
output layer of the network so let's
start by looking at some cool examples
of images that you can generate by using
an evolutionary approach in combination
with a very strong regularizer so here
what was done is you take a trained deep
convolutional network and you're going
to select a bunch of output classes so
in this case we'll look at the classes
baseball sunglasses and matchstick and
we can see that if we feed a normal
image these images get correctly
classified by the network but then we're
going to use an evolutionary approach to
generate synthetic images that are also
very good at exciting those specific
output classes and we can see that if we
use this evolutionary approach we
actually get images that look very
similar to the classes that it is trying
to excite so here for example the
baseball it doesn't really look like a
baseball but you can see and understand
why the network thinks that this might
be a baseball the same goes for the
sunglasses and for the matchsticks so
these patterns that are being found by
this evolutionary algorithm even though
we know that they are not real images
it's kind of understandable why the
network thinks that those might be the
specific classes we're looking for but
if we look at some additional examples
of generated images with the same
technique everything gets a little bit
more complicated because right here you
can see that even though a lot of these
images might have some of the patterns
that you would also recognize in the
actual classes a lot of them are very
unrecognizable and while for some
examples like the computer keyboard it's
still pretty clear what's going on
something like the assault rifle for
example doesn't look at all like the
real assault rifles that we know so we
can already see that something fishy is
going on here
and so remember that all these images
were generated using a very strong
regularization technique called CP PN so
let's look at what happens if we use
only gradient descent without any
regularization and we start from a
random noise image so here you can see a
bunch of these examples that were each
generated to maximally excite the chosen
output class so what you need to
remember from this is that we can use
gradient descent on input pixels to
generate images that to us humans look
like total noise but are very good at
maximally exciting output classes in
deep neural networks
remember all those media hype articles
that claim that neural nets are based on
the brain well I think that these images
pretty clearly show that our current
neural network architectures are doing
some drastically different things right
so now that we have that basis let's
introduce adversarial examples okay so
in all the previous examples while those
images were very good at fooling and
neural network it was pretty clear to us
that those were not real images they
were fake they were synthetically
generated but what if we started from an
existing image instead so here's what we
do we take a real-world input image X
that represents a panda bear
we run it through a convolutional
network and it gets correctly classified
as being a panda bear now starting from
this image we're first going to select a
random output neuron in the output layer
of our network that is different from
the true neuron that classifies panda
bears and then we're going to apply
gradient descent to the input pixels of
our panda bear in order to minimize the
classification loss with respect to that
newly chosen class neuron and so instead
of adjusting the network weights in
order to optimize our classifier which
is what you would normally do what
training we're just going to adjust the
input pixels until they fool the neural
network to make a wrong prediction and
so the final trick is to make sure that
our generated image looks as close as
possible to the original one so that we
can't see the difference and so there
are many different ways to generate
these adversarial examples but I want to
quickly highlight one very common one
which is the fast gradient sine method
so the fast gradient sine method simply
calculates the gradient with respect to
the input pixels in an image and then it
applies a sine operation to that
gradient matrix
and so basically what this matrix is
saying is for every single pixel in my
input image what would happen to the
activation of my target output neuron if
I increase or decrease the value of that
pixel and so finally we take this
thresholded gradient matrix we multiply
it by some small number epsilon and we
add it to the input image and so
obviously because we want to keep our
resulting generated image as close as
possible to the original what we want to
find is the minimal value of epsilon
that leads through a miss classification
so let's look at some striking examples
that were generated using the fast
gradient sign method so here are all
three images on the left are correctly
classified by the deep neural network in
the middle we can see the gradient
perturbations that we're going to add to
the images and then on the right side we
see the resulting adversarial examples
that look visually identical but the
neural network misclassifies with high
certainty as being an ostrich so there
are a few astonishing things about
adversarial examples the first is that
we can generate adversarial examples for
any known network architecture that we
have today so whether it's a vanilla
Network a recurrent Network a
convolutional network it doesn't matter
for every single one of them we can
generate adversarial examples in fact
adversarial examples are so strong and
so common that we can even generate them
for more traditional machine learning
models like linear regression random
forest SVM's you name it every single
one of them can be attacked using an
adversarial example a second
characteristic of these adversarial
examples is what we call cross model
generalization and this means that when
we create an adversarial example that
fools Network type a in a lot of cases
that adversarial example will also fool
Network type B and it will turn out in a
few minutes that this is a very very
strong characteristic that makes these
adversarial examples so hard to defend
against and so here for example we can
see a bunch of adversarial images
generated using the amnesty ADA set on
the left side you can see adversarial
examples for a linear classifier just
normal in your regression model in the
middle we see adversarial examples for a
normal vanilla net and we can see that
both of these ad classes of adversarial
examples look very very similar to the
original images whereas on the right
side what we've done is we've
added a lot of caution noise to the
input images and now for a human is very
difficult to actually predict what
number is written there but the network
a normal network still does a pretty
good job at doing this and so what this
shows is that there's this very
unintuitive thing going on where if an
image looks very very similar visually
to us we would expect that the network
would also classify that image correctly
whereas if there is a lot of noise being
added then we would sort of assume that
a network would be able to make mistakes
but it turns out that the opposite is
true here's another example with a whole
bunch of faces and it turns out it's
very very easy to run gradient descent
on these input images to make sure that
every single one of these images is
classified as being Keanu Reeves and
very interestingly it turns out that
these adversarial attacks are not just
in computer vision you can actually
apply the same technique in something
like natural language processing as well
let's have a look so if you think about
websites like Amazon or booking.com
TripAdvisor or things like that a lot of
their information and business value
actually comes from users that post
reviews on the websites and nowadays
most of that information is crunched and
aggregated using things like sentiment
analysis so here you can see a bunch of
very intriguing examples where by only
changing a couple of characters in a
sentence we are able to completely flip
the classification of a natural language
model alright so now that we know how
simple adversarial attacks work what can
we do to defend against them so I'm sure
that many of you will have figured out
that in order to generate an adversarial
example you need access to the gradient
in your network and so if you look at
some of the main computer vision api's
like Google or Amazon or Microsoft that
we have today most of them can be run in
two modes the first mode is where you
simply run an image through the API and
it spits back a bunch of labels that
might be present in that input image and
for every single label you get a
probability and this means that if you
make a slight adjustment to your input
image you can actually see the result on
the probabilities of those labels and
you can figure out if you are headed
towards an adversarial example and so an
obvious defense would be to hide that
probability vector and simply return the
most likely class label
and by doing this an attacker wouldn't
have access to the gradient of our model
but does this really solve our problem
well it turns out unfortunately it
doesn't basically we have two types of
adversarial attacks we have the white
box attacks where you have access to
that gradient to the model and we have
the black box attack where you don't
have that access and so the general idea
behind a black box attack is that you're
gonna use the API itself to label your
own training data so you select any kind
of input image that you want to test you
run it through the API and then that
label is what you get back as a
supervision signal and what you can do
that is you can generate a whole bunch
of images they can be real or they can
be synthetic and you use the labels that
are spit back from the API as training
data and you train your own model to
sort of simulate what the actual API is
doing internally and remember that
characteristic about cross model
generalization well this is why
adversarial attacks are so difficult to
defend against it is because if you have
your own local model and you use it to
generate an adversarial example there is
a very high chance that that adversarial
example will also fool your target
Network and it turns out you can do even
simple stuff than that you can start
from any chosen image add a whole bunch
of noise vectors to it and eventually
you will hit some kind of classification
border where the maximum likelihood
label will switch and then you know that
you've hit the border and then the only
thing you have to do is figure out the
smallest amount of noise that you need
to add to the input image in order to
make it flip so hiding the gradient of a
model doesn't work then there were a
couple of people who suggested that okay
these adversarial examples there might
be a theoretical problem but there won't
be problems in the real world because if
you have something like a self-driving
car that is looking at images then those
images are constantly changing in
distance and angle and direction things
like that so there are a whole bunch of
transformations that are being done to
the images and an adversarial example
will only be adversarial in one specific
position well it turns out that this is
not true either in fact you can generate
adversarial examples that when you print
them on a piece of paper and then you
take a whole bunch of pictures of them
they are still adversarial from every
single point
and people have gone even further in
this video you can see a 3d printed
turtle that went filmed with the camera
every single frame gets classified by a
neural network as being a rifle I mean
how crazy is that so currently there are
two accepted defense mechanisms against
adversarial examples the first is called
the reactive strategy and in this case
what you're gonna do is next your normal
classifier you're gonna train a second
network that simply tries to detect
adversarial examples and whenever a new
adversarial example comes in you're just
going to reject it from your second
classifier but I think everybody will
feel that this is not really a
satisfactory solution because if you
want to do this you effectively have to
double the infrastructure that you need
to run your computer vision API and on
top of that we know from our human
vision system that there are physical
systems that are robust to this type of
adversarial examples so there must be a
way to have our neural networks do the
same the second is called the proactive
strategy and this is where you're
actually going to include adversarial
examples inside the training loop of
your neural network and surprisingly it
turns out that these adversarial
examples while training are very good
regular risers for existing models so on
the right side here you can see what the
effect is of adversarial training on
adversarial examples which is obviously
improving it but on the left side very
interestingly we can see that
adversarial training also improves the
classification on normal samples and so
to finalize what's at stake here is
really big on the one side I think these
adversarial examples hint at some very
interesting new research directions that
we can use to improve our existing
models so firstly fixing the problem of
adversarial examples is very crucial for
the existing machine learning
applications that we have in place today
assuring their safety is crucial but
then finally and most importantly I
think fixing the issue of adversarial
examples can open up a whole new range
of machine learning applications because
imagine that you are a company that
wants to build fast cars what companies
do now today is they build a car frame
and then you're going to test this car
frame using some kind of a physics
simulation model that can do fluid
dynamics to test how fast that car could
drive but the problem with this approach
is there
it is very computationally intensive and
so obviously we would like to use a
neural network to optimize the frame of
the car itself but the problem is that
if we do this right now the only thing
we end up with is an adversarial example
so instead of generating an actually
faster car frame a gradient descent
technique today would just lead to an
adversarial example to fool that model
into thinking that the car would be
faster and so fixing the problem of
adversarial examples can open a whole
new range of machine learning
applications from a I assisted 3d design
to drug discovery and many many more and
then a final question is the we humans
actually have adversarial examples
ourselves and I think the answer is yes
we do because if you look at something
like optical illusions for example in
this image everybody sees lines that
don't look parallel but we all know that
they are and I think this is exactly
what adversarial examples are there are
images where we see something that we
shouldn't be seeing so we can see that
our human visual system can also be
fooled with certain examples but very
clearly we are robust to the adversarial
examples that fool our neural network
classifiers and this is why I am pretty
optimistic that there are fundamental
solutions to the problem of adversarial
examples that can open up a whole new
range of machine learning applications
all right I hope you enjoyed my take on
adversarial examples don't forget to
subscribe and I'd love to see you again
in the next episode of archived insights
you